well this morning changes are in the
works after that fatal alligator attack
at Disney World Disney you guys are
supposed to be squeaky clean we can't
believe how many times you've gotten
into trouble over the years you might
want to settle down before you ruffle
any more feathers it is nice to see that
even you guys aren't perfect some of
your riskiest moments are pretty
shocking a lot is going on under those
mouse ears who knew you were capable of
such precarious behaviors wait until you
guys hear about all the crazy things
that got Disney into trouble
Disney is supposed to be picture perfect
but even they get into hot water
sometimes here are 10 risky things I got
Disney in trouble keep watching to find
out about the backlash Disney faced over
a bullying scandal and Emax while some
fans praised the Disney Channel show
Andy Mac for introducing a gay character
others weren't very happy about it
in the season 2 premiere Andy's best
friend Cyrus Goodman realizes that he
and Andy both have a crush on the same
boy Jonah I'm gay conservative group 1
Million Moms which is ironically run by
male members blasted the show for quote
choosing to abandoned family friendly
entertainment by introducing this
coming-out story cool
however the criticism didn't stop Andy
Mac from becoming one of the most
popular shows on the Disney Channel teen
beach movie while on set the Disney
Channel's teen beach movie Maia Mitchell
and Ross Lynch suffered matching
injuries
Ross tripped while running on set and
got a deep cut in his foot Maia cut her
foot when she fell off her surfboard
requiring a two-day hospital stay but in
the end Maya said it was worth it
because in the movie you can see
matching bandages on their feet Disney
had to make a statement that the proper
precautions were being taken to ensure
the safety of everyone in the film The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody do you guys
remember when the Cheetah Girls and
Chris Brown guest-starred in an episode
of sweet life back in 2008 it seemed to
come out of nowhere the episode would
have been fine but then Chris Brown got
in major trouble for assaulting his then
girlfriend Rihanna in 2009
together right now we just having fun
Disney Channel didn't want to tarnish
their squeaky-clean reputation by having
a show that featured the singer so they
decided to pull the episode and stopped
airing it all together
Olaf's frozen adventure did anyone else
go to the movie theater to see Coco only
to be forced to sit through a 20-minute
frozen short first if you were mad about
it you're not alone everyone left fans
with young children were not pleased
that their squirmy kids had to sit
through the longest short ever before
getting to the feature film after all of
the backlash Disney decided to pull the
short film from the film block good
called Disney Ally times controversy in
2017 the LA Times released a scathing
two-part article about Disney's bad
dealings with the city of Anaheim Disney
got so mad they bans the LA Times from
attending and reviewing their
pre-release screenings so the LA Times
exposed that too eventually
Disney came to its senses and let the
newspaper back in alligator attack one
family experienced their worst nightmare
while staying at the Disney Grand
Floridian Resort and Spa an unexpected
alligator attack resulted in an
irreversible tragedy Disney was
horrified at the life-shattering
incident that's a tough one to come back
from Disney's California Adventure when
the theme park across from Disneyland
opened in 2001 it was met with mediocre
reviews park goers complained that there
weren't enough rights for kids among
many other issues Disney had to make
some changes and add new rides to win
back the affection of tourists it worked
and now Disney's California Adventure is
usually packed year round
Aladdin in the live-action release of
Disney's Aladdin fans were perplexed by
the makeup - used on the background
performers apparently Disney put brown
makeup on white performers to make them
look darker people were not amused with
Disney's use of blackface and accused
the studio of racism Disney tried to
excuse this by claiming they needed
people with specialized abilities which
only made matters worse
Disney totally could have found the
right performers for the gig you were
right people see what they want to see
Aladdin is
so their statement did not go over well
at all
mana rel on fire back in 1985 something
awful happened at Walt Disney World in
Epcot the rear car of the monorail
suddenly bursts into flames
causing passengers to have to break the
windows to escape seven passengers were
treated for smoke inhalation that could
have ruined the parks reputation luckily
for Disney their image eventually
recovered and the incident has long
since been forgotten always check your
exits everyone Jesse
Disney had to take down an episode of
Jesse due to complaints about bullying
behavior on the show in the original cut
Jesse Bertram and the kids were making
fun of Stewart for not being able to eat
gluten and you're gonna be eating some
gluten-free
xiri through a pancake at Stewart which
freaks him out then Robbie said parents
of children with food allergies were not
happy at all it is not cool to pick on
somebody or prank them with foods they
are allergic to seriously a kid could be
severely hurt from that type of behavior
or worse responding to pressure from a
change.org online petition Disney
stopped the episode from airing in a
public statement Disney said they will
re-evaluate its references to gluten
restrictions in the characters diet
Disney asked fans to please accept our
apologies and that was the end of that
which Disney controversy was the most
shocking to you sound off in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things thanks for watching we'll see you
soon
[Music]